the IBM Quantum herin processor IBM
Quantum system 2 and the ga of Watson
x.g governance all on this episode of
IBM Tech now what's up y'all my name is
Ian and I am back to bring you the
latest and greatest news and
announcements about IBN
technology last week at the annual IBM
Quantum Summit in New York we debuted
IBM Quantum Heron the first in a new
series of utility scale Quantum
processors IBM Quantum heron Fe in
architecture engineered over the past
four years to deliver IBM's highest
performance metrics and lowest error
rates as demonstrated earlier this year
in a 127 Cubit IBM Quantum Eagle
processor IBM Quantum systems can now
serve as a scientific tool to explore
utility scale classes of problems in
chemistry physics and materials Beyond
Brute Force classical simulation of
quantum mechanics since that
demonstration leading researchers
scientists and Engineers have expanded
demonstrations of utility scale Quantum
Computing to confirm its value in
exploring Uncharted computational
Territory at 133 cubits IBM Quantum
Heron is the first in IBM's new class of
performant processors with significantly
improved error rates offering a five
times improvement over the previous best
records set by IBM Eagle to learn all
about IBM Quantum Herm check out the
link in the description of this video at
the same Quantum sum we also unveiled
IBM Quantum system 2 the company's first
modular quantum computer and the
Cornerstone of our Quantum Centric
supercomputing architecture it combines
scalable cryogenic infrastructure and
classical runtime servers with modular
Cubit control electronics and it
features three IBM Quantum Heron
processors this architecture combines
Quantum communication and computation
assisted by classical Computing
resources and leverages a middleware
layer to appropriately integrate Quantum
and classical workflows as part of the
newly expanded 10-year IBM Quantum
development road map IBM plans for the
system to also house our future
generations of quantum processors to
learn more about IBM Quantum system 2
hit the link
below to finish things off today we're
excited to announce the general
availability of Watson x.g governance
before AI can help your business reach
new levels of productivity you need to
be able to trust what it's doing luckily
Watson x.g governance is designed to be
a One-Stop shop for businesses
navigating how to deploy and manage both
llm and ml models it provides tools to
help you mitigate risks and accelerate
responsible transparent and explainable
generative Ai and ml workflows Watson
x.g governance can help you
operationalize AI with confidence in
three main ways first is compliance
where you can manage AI to address
internal policies and Industry standards
and help prepare for upcoming
regulations and Poli policies worldwide
second is risk management where you can
proactively detect and mitigate risks
while monitoring for fairness bias drift
and new llm metrics and third is life
cycle governance where you can manage
Monitor and govern AI models from IBM
open source communities and other model
providers to learn more and get started
with Watson x.g governance hit the link
below thanks so much for joining me
today for this episode of IBM Tech now
if you're interested in learning more
about the topics I've covered make sure
you explore the links in the description
of this video and again please don't
forget to subscribe to our channel to
stay up todate on what's going on in
Tech
now